I would argue like three eras in
Psychiatry you know what friends of mine
have called Psychiatry 1.0 2.0 3.0 and
you know the first era was this era in
around Freud and this idea that it was a
Content issue right and in a life
experience issue which is partially true
it's not that that's not true it's just
not complete and so then the solution is
a Content solution Allah you know
initially psychoanalysis all the way
through kind of modern forms of
psychotherapy the limitation of that led
us to Psychiatry 2.0 right this idea
that we serendipitously found the first
antipsychotics and first
anti-depressants and we were able to
deinstitutionalize you know primarily
schizophrenia patients out of impatient
like Asylum stays with these drugs which
kind of flew in the face of this being a
Content issue well if we're moving all
of these chemicals around in the brain
then it must be that there's a
deficiency or an imbalance or whatever
and that led us to recent history where
you know there's quite a bit of you know
prescribing of oral antidepressants and
all that stuff and the third ERA this
kind of circuit era that I think we're
we're in now and i' I'd argue we kind of
were entering in 10 years ago but I
think we're pretty squarely at the the
beginning of now flies in the face of
that right if I can take a patient as
sever as dear jeman get her out of it in
a very quick time frame and and looking
normal and holding that for a long time
and there was no chemical exchange right
there's nothing that went into her
system then it gets you into this newer
way of thinking about it it's a circuit
problem the useful thing about this
framing one it's seemingly consistently
true in the sense that we we're through
all the various modalities seeing these
differences but you know more
importantly it lets you integrate past
ideas into that concept right drugs act
on circuits therapy acts on circuits but
focal neuromodulation is a really direct
way of acting on those same circuits and
so from a patient standpoint I think
it's very empowering because we're not
saying there's something inherently like
missing or too much for you you're
constrained to having to to take these
these exogenous chemicals to to kind of
stay well but rather like there's a
circuit there's a a miswiring sort of
misfiring sort of problem and if we can
reroute that information then you can
feel well and I think that there's a
level of empowerment that comes to
that